okay
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for
kids and others um
let's see we had some questions uh
left over from
uh last time
so let's see he had a question here from
oh flamio
how does the bloomberg terminal work
okay i'll see what i can do with that
so bloomberg terminals are
a sort of the the leading brand
of uh ways to get financial information
um certainly not the only way uh for
example involved from alpha and more
from language we have access to lots of
financial information
um let me explain what it is and and how
that all works
so uh first point is when
when uh there are public companies
companies where anybody
pretty much can buy shares in the
company so a company like apple or
microsoft or google
or
[Music]
all kinds of other companies um have
the the you can buy shares in the
company so you can buy point zero zero
zero one percent of the company
by spending x amount of money every
every
at every moment some people are trying
to buy shares in the company some people
are
trying to sell shares in the company so
there's a market
and people are deciding how much are
these shares actually worth
so if suddenly one day uh it's like
um uh the um
uh suddenly uh some company seems very
looks like it's doing really cool stuff
everybody wants to buy shares in that
company
and so they're prepared to spend so that
it will tend to be the case they say oh
this company
it used to be that this company shares
were ten dollars each but people say
well i'm so keen to buy shares in this
company i'm gonna pay eleven
for the shares in that company and other
people who own shares in the company
already said
great we'll sell you the shares for 11
or another thing might be
people are like this company is not
doing very well
um uh i want to uh uh you know i really
want to get rid of my shares in the
company
somebody says well i'll take them off
your hands for nine dollars and say fine
i'll i'll sell them for nine dollars
so at any moment there's always this
this uh
uh sort of process happening between
buyers and sellers of shares in a
company
and you know how do you determine what
the shares should be worth
well nobody really knows it's determined
by what people are prepared to pay for
them
um now people will say there are
theories in economics about
how you determine how much the shares of
a company are worth it it's really a
question in the end of how much is the
whole company worth because
the shares in the company are just
defining like them
a company might have um a million shares
and and so if each share is worth a
hundred dollars
the whole company would then be worth
100 million dollars
and usually the way it works is that
some fraction of the shares in a company
in a public company are um available
in um uh to the public
and some fraction are are held um
by inside people and so on now that i
think that i'm trying to remember how
many
i think worldwide in the large exchanges
there are around
40 000 public companies maybe maybe in
the us
5 000. i'm not sure i don't remember
exactly
um most most public companies are quite
large
there are some small companies that um
maybe they were once large and they
became smaller and they're still public
companies they're so called pink sheet
companies that i guess
are called pink sheets for companies
because their descriptions of them were
on pink sheets so to speak um
but mostly most companies that are
public companies
the whole company is worth billions of
dollars and so when you uh
you know the shares you have each share
might cost let's say ten dollars
you own a tiny tiny fraction of the
company okay
so then there's the question of uh what
uh these shares um people are
continually saying every day
there's a all kinds of people saying i
want to buy shares in the company i want
to sell shares in the company
some companies are sort of thickly
traded in the sense that
every day there's a large volume of
people saying i want to buy i want to
sell and that's happening maybe every
second
other companies it's like nobody's
really paying a lot of attention to this
company so maybe they're only
you know 10 transactions in a whole day
of people buying shares selling shares
in the company
and um you know the question of of how
much the company should be worth
is this really a company that should be
worth uh 10 billion
100 billion dollars a trillion dollars
whatever um
that's really in as a practical matter
determined by how much people will pay
for it
there are economic theories one of the
uh sort of traditional economic theories
says
um the so
it's a it's a theory that says basically
the the current
price of the company should be a measure
of sort of the discounted value
of future dividends from the company
what does that mean
well so a company when it makes things
like a company might be making
i don't know cell phones or something
that the company
is people are paying money to get those
cell phones
so they might be paying for each cell
phone they might pay
300 um but it will cost the company a
certain amount to make each of those
cell phones and all the research and
development the company does
all the marketing campaigns the company
runs and so on it might in the end be
costing the company
uh 280 dollars effectively to make
to those will be the expenses on a 300
cell phone so the company is then it's
revenue
total amount of money it's bringing in
is 300 per cell phone
but the amount of money that it is
making as profit as opposed to money
that's got to spend
expenses might be only 20 per cell phone
and so
for any company you can look at its
financial data and you'll see a revenue
and then you'll see a a net income and
the net income is the profit
of what the company the the the money
that the company sort of keeps
after it's paid the expenses that it has
the expenses might be the actual
components of the things it's making it
might be the the cost of the employees
the company has it might be
what it's spending to ship the products
here and there
etc etc etc there are there are other
issues
when the company is like let's say it
buys it builds a factory
there are all kinds of questions about
exactly how the the the money that's
spent to build the factory is accounted
for
because you know you might build a
factory for hundreds of millions of
dollars one year
but that factory will last you for 20
years and so
the way that accounting is set up you
don't say that
all the expense of building the factory
is all taken
in the year when you actually build the
factory it's spread out over a large
number of years and different kinds of
things
uh have the amount of money that's spent
on them spread out over different
numbers of years
in terms of where it shows up as an
expense with respect to accounting
so it's a little tricky to figure all of
that out but in the end
a company if it is uh if it's going to
be a sort of surviving company
in the end presumably it's got to make a
profit
it's got to make more money than it
spends
and in the end when companies make more
money than they spend
one kind of expects that the people who
own the company will be getting
some part of that money and the way that
works is the company pays dividends it
says
if you own a share of the of the company
this year
then the company will pay you a dollar
um as
of its profit for that particular
associated with that particular share
now there are plenty of in the
technology area plenty of companies
don't pay dividends
in areas like utility companies power
utilities things like that
um they they sort of once you've built
the power plant and it's running and so
on it costs a certain amount but it's
going to make money
and it pays dividends to its
shareholders and so one
theory of sort of how much your company
should be worth is
you wait and you see you imagine the
future and you say
you know 20 years from now this company
will be paying these huge dividends
because
everything it'll it'll have built up all
this stuff and they'll just be making
huge profits you say well that's 20
years from now but what about now
well you could always say well what if i
borrowed the money now
and then i would be paying interest on
that money there's there's an effective
value
of what the money that would be paid 20
years from now there's an effective
value of that money now
based on i borrow the money and then i'm
paying interest for that period of time
the so-called time value of money
and um the uh so one theory would be
companies are worth sort of the
discounted future value of their
dividends
this theory is probably nonsense this is
a sort of has been a traditional theory
of you know that's ultimately what a
company is worth the fact is
what people usually these days
particularly in technology companies
they're usually thinking uh you know the
big thing the big idea that people have
is i buy stock
now uh for you know ten dollars a share
i wait until it goes up to fifteen
dollars a share
and then i sell it to somebody else who
is prepared to buy it at 15
a share and i make it i make myself a
five dollar profit
i'm not imagining that sometime in the
future the company will be paying
dividends
so it's really a matter of sort of uh
trading with other people with these for
these shares
rather than what will the fundamental
thing of the company be
but okay so so then the question is uh
you people are
trading shares somebody's buying the
shares for eleven dollars nine dollars
et cetera et cetera et cetera
throughout the day for any given
publicly traded company
there will be prices being set how are
those prices set well every time a
transaction is done
that defines a price so and so bought
the shares for
eleven dollars and fifteen cents okay
that's a that's an event
that's a price that was set somebody
else buys it for 11.
and 10 cents okay that's another price a
little bit lower than the previous one
and so throughout the day there'll be
these sort of little
events that are being that are happening
of
uh these these trades that are going on
and each one has a price that gets
reported
how do those trades work well different
uh public when you say a company is a
public company
if you really get into more of the
details it's public on a certain
exchange
so in the u.s two big exchanges are
uh the new york stock exchange and
nasdaq
um the nasdaq um
nasdaq is an electronic exchange the new
york stock exchange is a more
sort of human brokered exchange how do
things actually work
well in the end what's happening is
somebody will be people will be saying
i'm prepared to sell
this stock for this amount of money
other people will be saying i'm prepared
to buy this stock for this amount of
money
those have to be matched up somehow
that's in a sense what the exchanges are
doing
is to make those matches happen and in
the case of nasdaq it's happening
electronically in the case of new york
stock exchange
there actually is i think still a
physical place where there are sort of
specialists
associated with each company who are
there with a little boost effectively
and and they're the ones who are dealing
with the actual transactions that are
happening
but either way in the end a transaction
happens
and as soon as the transaction happens
the information about that transaction
becomes this sort of price fact about
that company
and this idea of sort of price facts
about companies it's been going a long
time
it's been going for the whole history of
stock exchanges
and back in the day you know 100 and
something years ago
this was there was a ticker tape that
was quite literally
something where there was every
transaction that was made there was sort
of a
a a um
it was so recorded on a tape and it was
um
uh it was you know this company you know
company and every all
these companies have have uh ids and and
back in
when when the stock exchanges were young
100 and something years ago
you know there will be companies like
you know t i think t is still at t
probably um but but there were companies
that were you know they would have
single letter
acronyms these days um they're there you
know like
apple is aapl microsoft it's msft
those are those are on the nasdaq
exchange i think that there are
usually three letter or two-letter
acronyms on on new york stock exchange
uh whether a smaller number of companies
and so on but but but but each one of
these is you know a company is
designated by some
ticker symbol and then that uh every
sort of uh transaction
is you know okay you know msft and then
there's some number i don't remember at
all what microsoft's
stock price is now you know whatever it
is five hundred dollars a show
whatever i don't know what it is um the
the um
uh every transaction it's it's the the
sort of the ticker
name of the company and then how much it
was uh how much the transaction happened
for
and needless to say there's more
complexity because there's a spread in
the transaction
because somebody is taking a commission
on actually doing the transaction
etcetera etcetera etcetera but
in a first approximation there is a
price at which that transaction took
place
okay so now the question is what happens
so so what's being generated is the sort
of ticker tape
of all these successive transactions
millions and millions of them these days
per day
and um then the the question is how does
how do you know about that well back in
the day for example
one of thomas edison's early inventions
was a better
sort of ticker tape device for getting
the information
associated with stock transactions uh
distributed and back in the day used to
be distributed by telegraph lines
um uh these days it's distributed in
other ways
and and what what what actually
eventually happens well what eventually
happens is from these exchanges these
exchanges
are basically putting up electronic
information that says
this transaction happened this is the um
this is the amount the transaction was
for
and so on and so when we uh well from
alpha or bloomberg
you know making bluebird terminals um uh
we're getting the information from the
exchanges
um sometimes through brokers who who
provide the information from the
exchanges but
it's basically from the exchanges uh
this series of
uh this was the price that this just
happened this was the price that this
just happened and so on and so on and so
on
and that's that's essentially when you
see prices displayed that's what's
that's what's going on
and then you know obviously one one
stores
the information on historical prices
among and so one can go back and see you
know what was the stock chart
um through the year or whatever of this
particular company etc
um so that that's that's that's the
basic story now it gets more elaborate
when you're dealing with things other
than
stocks there are more complicated issues
associated with getting price
information
for these other kinds of things and and
people
are often very concerned about just
exactly how quickly can you get that
stock information
so for example uh people have trading
strategies they might have
a very simple trading strategy where
they say i'm going to buy this thing
as soon as it goes below 100 a share
okay and they
they just set up some order that says
buy it when it goes out below 100
a share but people who do quantitative
finance and use a bunch of fancy
mathematical methods
to try to beat the market what they're
doing is
they're doing much more elaborate kinds
of things where they may make a huge
number of trades so the
sort of extreme case is so called high
frequency trading where you might be
trading
many times a second some particular
stock
and you're watching for very detailed
things about what's happening
as as other people trade that stock or
as
uh as these as these prices change and
so
it becomes a big sort of issue can you
get
um uh when you're doing that it really
matters
uh what was the price when and so
the price is set at some exchange let's
say you're
you're you're trading a stock in in the
uk and it's on the london stock exchange
so there's some moment at which a trade
happens on the london stock exchange
and a price is set for that particular
stock
so if you are then sort of comparing
that with the price of some stock in new
york
that's being traded on the new york
stock exchange one of the issues is how
quickly can you get can you sort of
exchange that information
and so people go to very great lengths i
mean there was a
recent effort to put a new fiber optic
cable under the atlantic
um to be able to get just a little bit
quicker information
from for example the london stock
exchange in new york and things like
this
and if you're doing these strategies
where you're like trading many many
times a second
it starts to matter that there's an
extra 50 milliseconds 100 milliseconds
of delay in getting the information
about about um
uh that that stock trade but there are
all kinds of things that that um
uh also happen in terms of getting
information like like for instance
there's an exchange i don't know quite
what's happened to it but there's an
exchange
that was sort of an uh another exchange
that had been set up was a very
electronic exchange where sort of the
deal
was um you simply if you want to get
information about
about stock trades you simply it's like
a place where it's like a data center
where you just pay to have a rack where
you can put your your computer equipment
and then sort of all of the data like
this sort of a a modern electronic
version of this kind of ticker tape idea
sort of all the data of stock trades
so it's flowing through this whole data
center and if you happen to have your
rack of electronics there
you can pick up the information from it
so anyway that was a
a bit of a um uh a story um
uh um
about um uh how how information about
financial uh
transactions um gets uh gets delivered
to people
and you know one of the questions that's
more of a science question i suppose
is if you look at one of these stock
charts it's always wiggling around
singling
seemingly randomly in fact it's a pretty
good approximation to a lot of stock
prices
that they are random walks in the sense
that they have an equal chance to go up
and to go down
and random walks have all kinds of
characteristics and all kinds of things
you can calculate
about what random walks do in truth
they're not quite random walks the most
important effect
about a stock price is that it can't be
negative
that is the or at least in most
situations it can't possibly be negative
a company can never be worth a negative
amount of money
you might have said that about something
like oil but there was a time a few
months ago
when the effective price of oil on the
market uh
actually managed to go negative because
for for various reasons which
um but but that's in the normal course
of events
price for stock is always positive so
that's a kind of a constraint on this
random walk
and there are also constraints about
whether the the tail of the random walk
is heavy whether
whether stocks tend to kind of get to
larger values more
or not and um so there are some
deviations from that but in a first
approximation it's kind of a
a pretty good approximation to a random
walk and the question is why is it that
way
and is that because of the fact that
you're always getting new information
about stocks and people are always
finding out new things
and so there's always sort of random
data coming in and that's why it's
randomly moving around or is it more
something to do with the dynamics of
individual
traders who are like oh i'm going to buy
this i'm going to sell this oh i'm going
to watch what the other guy's doing i'm
going to do this i'm going to do that
and increasingly in some stocks the the
if you just look at the sheer volume of
trades that are going on
a large fraction end up being associated
with things like high frequency trading
and other kind of algorithmic
you know computers working out what to
trade rather than a human saying
oh i really like that company it's
making really cool stuff i'm going to
buy more shares in it
um it's uh so that
um it becomes sort of a question of if
you have all these computers with all
their algorithms and they're figuring
out i should buy i should sell i should
buy
et cetera what does the what is the
collection of computers
who are trading with each other what
does that do to stock prices
and maybe that leads to some of these
random fluctuations and that's actually
probably a good thing
because if there's sort of everything's
happening randomly and some
somehow there's a sort of perturbation
to this somehow there's something
uh sort of very surprising that happens
it's still there's enough randomness
going on that the system you know
another computer will decide this and
another one the person will decide that
it's all sort of randomly
uh you know kept uh kept in some kind of
equilibrium kept under control
but if on the other hand it's really
just uh you know the market is just five
computers
and they all have similar algorithms and
something happens in the world and
suddenly they will say oh we've all got
to sell
it's like okay great they're all selling
uh who's buying
they're the only people in that market
and so when it's like
they're only sellers and there are no
buyers what does that do to the price
that means if they're only sellers and
no buyers the price just gonna go down
down down down down
because eventually you should be able to
find a buyer if you you know if you had
a ten dollar thing and you're prepared
to sell it for a dollar
eventually somebody's going to buy it
presumably but let's say
it was you know the only things in the
market with these computers that were
deciding what to do
it might just the price might go to zero
the price might go you know it might all
go crazy
and so so that's a sort of a concern and
it's better for there to be a certain
amount of randomness
and in fact in in the markets one of the
roles of exchanges
sometimes controversial is to stop
trading when things go too weird and too
unstable
all right anyway a little bit of um a
little bit about the financial
world all right let me see
uh all kinds of questions here
um it's a question from humanities i had
mentioned
um uh somebody had asked in a different
live stream about
um a sort of amateur satellite launching
and i was mentioning a friend of mine
who had a small micro satellite i don't
know how big they are they're little
cube
sats i think they're they're about um a
few inches across
and they get they get launched in big
collections
by by satellite launch companies and
then you know
you're up in space you're you know 100
miles up whatever it is
and um then you know the sort of the the
rocket opens up and there's this whole
row of little tiny satellites and it's
like uh they all get pushed out into
space and there they are
they're all floating out in space um in
orbit
uh and uh what happened to this friend
of mine is they were not
did not have their act as well together
as they should have done in figuring out
you know uh how they pick up the signals
from the antenna from their cubesat
et cetera et cetera et cetera and they
lost the satellite
so the question is did they find the
satellite again and the answer is no
they did not find their satellite again
and it's kind of tough because you know
it's like like something goes wrong with
your computer and it's in space
what do you do well you know you might
say
uh let's reboot that computer well who's
going to reboot it
what's been done on deep space probes is
that
they'll they'll often have you know
multiple computers and they'll have
mechanisms
for for sort of failover from one to
another and in the end they'll have sort
of mechanisms to reboot things
that are sort of i actually don't
completely know how this works
um now that i think about it i mean i've
i've um
uh it's kind of a weird thing because
because
people are still sending signals to
spacecraft that were launched you know
30 40 years ago
um when computers were much more
primitive and it's like there's a
particular machine code that this
computer
that this sat that this deep space probe
is running
and um uh you know every so often you
can reload new code in there
and say start executing again the way it
actually works
there's a deep space tracking network
that's a bunch of radio antennas in
different places on the earth
and as the earth rotates different
antennas will go
will be sort of lined up to be in the
right direction to communicate with a
deep space probe that's near jupiter
let's say or that's out um
uh you know past past neptune or
whatever else
and and the way it works is that there's
they're all sort of time
sliced and so at a particular time of
day
the such and such spacecraft knows to
kind of wake up
and that's that's when it will be that's
when data will be sent to it
um and and i guess i guess also the
other way around maybe it's more more
important the other way around
there'll be a particular time of day
when that spacecraft when the
when the um the the the satellite
um the the radio telescope dishes
will be turned in the direction of that
particular satellite to say okay what do
you have to say
today and um and then it's possible to
upload
new instructions uh to these spacecraft
and get them to start executing those
new instructions and you better not make
too many coding mistakes because
if things go horribly wrong you could
end up with a uh well i
actually just shut your antenna down
never never
you know never have it um uh powered up
again
and then it's like well i'm sorry the
thing you know your spacecraft is
somewhere near neptune
and it's never going to listen to you
again game is over so that's a that's a
thing to avoid
um and uh uh it's impressive that um
they're like um uh what is it the um
uh i guess the pioneer spacecraft are
now
gone is that right and the voyager
spacecraft
which are are still in communication at
like um
35 years after their launch or some such
um but uh and by the way i mean the
other issue is
you've got to maintain power on a
spacecraft and how do you do that
um you know normally in earth orbit
satellites are powered by solar panels
um because you know we're we're close
enough to the sun that we can get enough
solar radiation that we can
you know use photovoltaics and um and
actually
uh produce power and when you're making
a deep space probe
you can't do that and instead they use
essentially nuclear batteries
um where they're using um
uh where you're too far from the sun so
you can't expect to get
enough um enough solar radiation i mean
it's just like on the earth it's easier
to have
solar panels work near the equator than
it is near the poles
because they're just the the angles are
such that you just get more
more sunlight near the equator than you
do in the other poles which is why it's
colder near the poles
um but uh you know when when you're out
sort of past the orbit of jupiter the
sun is a little tiny spot
in the sky and and so it doesn't uh
you're not you're not able to get enough
solar radiation so instead you have to
use these kind of nuclear
um there's not not not likely to a power
station where you're
um but more just you're using nuclear
decays
to produce heat that allows you to make
make electricity
okay let me see um
well gosh many many questions here okay
so there's a question here
uh what are finding diagrams
okay this is going to take us in a
completely different direction
of um uh talking about things
so family diagrams are a thing in
physics um
they were actually invented by a
late friend of mine named dick fineman
um invented them in the 1940s
what are they well when you have
uh if you look at mata on a very small
scale you find things like electrons
um electrons exist in atoms and so on
the nucleus of atoms is made of protons
and neutrons which in turn are made of
quarks and gluons
uh sort of around the nucleus the stuff
responsible for all the sort of chemical
effects
of um of of atoms
are the electrons um that uh
that exist sort of uh in the in the
outer part of the atom
so one question is
if you take a photon particle of light
and you shine it you you have a beam of
photons
and you have a beam of electrons and the
two things kind of
hit each other sometimes an electron and
a photon will kind of
hit each other and scatter away so
they'll
and that process it's called compton
scattering um
after the the chap who discovered that
this um
it's um uh the a photon can
can interact with an electron okay so
the question is to describe that process
to say
just how often if you have a photon
coming in this direction it has a
certain energy an electron coming in
this direction has a certain energy
what's the chance that those two things
will actually scatter from each other
um and in effect it's often described in
terms of the cross-section
what does that mean well imagine you're
you're you're
you know firing an arrow at a target the
question of
what's the chance that you hit the
target well it depends a bit on how big
the target is as you
as you put your arrow in different
places the bigger the target
the more likely you are to hit the the
more likely the the the
cross section is when the cross section
is larger the probability of an
interaction between the arrow and the
target is bigger
actually in the in the kind of strange
sense of humor of nuclear physicists
back in the day
the um the the usual unit of
cross-sections for nuclei
for what's the chance that an electron
will hit a nucleus for example
it's measured in barns like you know you
could hit
uh you should be able to hit this bond
like a barn on a farm type thing
you know from miles away well it's
actually a nucleus which is really
really tiny so
it's not such an easy thing to hit but
it's kind of as a as a as a kind of a
joke
these things called bonds and typical
nuclear
uh the the the sort of effective nuclear
cross section for interactions is
sort of bonds when you're dealing with
particles
um the uh for example the the
probability that two protons if you fire
two protons each other
the probability that the the effective
cross section of the protons
is well it used to be on the order of 40
millibars um
actually as the energy typical particle
accelerators
as the energies of particle cells have
gone up progressively
as the energies of protons go up it
turns out that the chance that they
interact
increases slightly so i think it's
probably maybe 150 millibars at the
the um at the highest energies that
particle accelerators
that crash beams of protons well more
often beams of protons and antiprotons
together
uh will reach okay so the question is
how do you
how do you figure out given that you
have an electron with such and such an
energy a photon and such and such an
energy
maybe just an electron electron that's
another it's called i think it's called
molar scattering
is some scattering of electrons by
electrons
um what is the let's actually talk about
the electron electron case probably a
little bit easier
um so you've got two electrons that
they're
being fired at each other and um the uh
uh you've got these two beams of
electrons what's the chance that they
scatter
okay how do you work that out well
uh let's see this is what feynman
diagrams do
and they're basically a mathematical
procedure for working out the chance
that those two things can interact
so how do electrons interact with each
other well
the fundamental form of interaction
between electrons and photons
is an electron can emit or absorb a
photon so essentially
if you draw that as a diagram it's like
there's a line that represents the
electron
and then coming out of it there might be
it's usually drawn as a wiggly line
that represents the photon so either
you know the electron is going along it
either emits a photon or it absorbs a
photon and that's represented by this
by this piece of a diagram in which
there's a line for the electron and
there's a line for the photon
okay so how does electron electron
scattering work
well there's a line for one of the
electrons there's a line for the other
electron
and then what's happening is it's
exchanging there's an exchange of a
photon between these two electrons
so you draw another little line the
wiggly line that joins the line for one
electron in the line for the other
electron
and that's that represents the exchange
of one photon actually
officially it's a so-called virtual
photon it's a photon that isn't the kind
of photon that just
goes on forever and eventually you can
you know see it in your eye or something
like this it's a photon that is just
produced
for a very short period of time by one
of these electrons then absorbed by the
other electron
and the deal is in quantum mechanics if
you produce things for a short amount of
time
they kind of don't have to have their
usual characteristics like elect photons
are usually massless particles traveling
uh that travel at the speed of light
um in a virtual photon doesn't have to
be massless
so long as it sort of survives for a
short enough time
the the amount it can have an effective
mass that is
something that uh uh depending on how
short the time is as the time gets
shorter and shorter
it can be sort of more and more wrong
about the mass that it has
so anyway the the the how do you
represent
electron electron scattering so the the
first order feynman diagram is just
you've got these two lines for these two
electrons
you've got one photon being exchanged
between them okay so
what dick feynman then did was he gave
these rules that say
given that that's the diagram that
represents the scattering event
scattering process what's the chance
that that scattering process happens
so in that particular case the answer is
the um uh oh gosh um well i can tell you
what it is
it's okay so so the um the first thing
is
what's the fundamental probability that
an electron emits a photon
okay it's governed by a thing called the
fine structure constant
we usually denoted alpha and um uh
well the the the actual probability the
the
probability for a single emission is is
actually a lowercase e which is sort of
the square root of the fine structure
constant
but let's ignore that there's always two
ends to the line so it's always some
an e squared and then the the fine
structure constant alpha
is equal to about one over 137 so it
tells you that kind of the
the basic parameter that determines sort
of how likely
the electrons are to to emit a photon is
this alpha 1 over 137
okay so then if you want to work out the
actual probability there are some other
terms so i mean just to tell you
in um it's been a while since i thought
about this but um
that particular thing is there's a
there's a thing called the direct gamma
matrix which is a so
there's a formula basically involves p
slashes
and gamma muse and one over q squared
and so on
um the most important part of that
particular formula is the alpha
the the the um uh the the fundamental
probability of an
electromagnetic process happening the
fundamental probability that that a
a photon will an electron will emit a
photon and then
there's a term that is proportional to
one over the square of the momentum
transfer so if
if one electron is kind of uh kicking
the other electron by
by sending out a photon the photon is is
transferring some momentum
and that momentum is kind of you know
the one one
one electron is going along and uh it
uh you know it's going to kick the other
electron that so so for example the
electrons might be initially
going straight at each other and then
they kick each other to the point where
they go they scatter
and they go at a different angle the
size of that kick
is proportional to the amount of
momentum transfer and the formula in the
vitamin diagram
finding rules is there's a one over q
squared where q
is essentially the momentum transfer and
so anyway you put all these things
together you eventually get a formula
for the probability of the scattering
event that is electron electron
scattering
as a function of the momentum and energy
of the electrons and so on
okay so the what happens is the the
first approximation to that is you
exchange one photon
but you can also that the tricky thing
with feynman diagrams is
there's also higher order finding
diagrams it's like that's the first
order approximation
the next approximation is you exchange
two photons well if you imagine these
diagrams it's
it's that when you're exchanging one
photon it's just there's two lines and
there's one wiggly line between them
okay great
when there are two photons it gets a
little bit more complicated the two
photons
can either be parallel they can cross
over there are a bunch of different
diagrams
that uh for where the photons can go
each one of those diagrams the feynman
rules tell you
what essentially the probability implied
by that diagram is and you're going to
add up all those actually they're not
probabilities their circle probability
amplitudes
which can be negative and so on and when
you add them all up together
and take the sum of them and square them
you get the probability
but in any case you get all these
different pieces and each one has
certain rules
the mathematical rules that tell you how
to compute the thing
okay so so you say well well i did the
first order one that was that was alpha
times something or other
um and now but why don't i have to how
much do i have how many orders do i have
to go to
well the second order one involves alpha
squared
third order one involves alpha cubed the
second order one involves alpha square
because there are two photons involved
and each
each vertex each end whether where a
photon connects with the
with the electron it it gives you one
square root of an alpha so
so that the two ends of each one of
those photons gives you an alpha
okay so the good news is if alpha is one
over 137
then by the time the the by the time
you're the second order it's 1 over 137
squared third order 1 over 137 cubed
so that gives you the sense that you
don't have to go to very many orders
you're going to be able to get the right
answer
to um by just going to a small number of
orders
um in this what's called perturbation
expansion
um to to work out the scattering
probability
and so what happens with finding
diagrams is
one is one is doing these calculations
um and the calculations get more and
more elaborate as you go to higher and
higher orders the calculations get more
elaborate so
first of all it's pretty easy you can
kind of do those by hand
second order yeah it's getting a little
hard there's at least one loop
happening and there's integrals you have
to do around that loop and their
integrals over
over four dimensional space and it's a
little bit tricky and by the time you're
at
you know uh third or fourth order um
the uh things are getting really hard
and that's actually why
when when i started using computers to
do um uh to do sort of mathematical
calculations one of the big things i
wanted to do
was higher order finding diagram
calculations calculations where you're
working out many loops
and in fact the the the one of those
that's been worked the most detail
is the thing called the anomalous
magnetic moment of the electron
um and that's been worked out to eighth
order and at eighth order
you are you know you're routinely
spending years of computer time
doing all the calculations for these
filemen diagrams um and by the way
by the time you've worked things out to
eighth order you are dealing with i
don't know
ten decimal places or more of um of
precision
so it's one of the most most remarkable
successes
of sort of physics has been the correct
calculation of things like the
theological magnetic moment of the
electron
um which have been you know with a lot
of effort they're calculated using these
feminine diamond rules
and by golly you get the right answer
you measure an experiment
is exactly right um and it gets a little
tricky because by the time you're at
that level of precision
you're starting to see effects from
things that aren't just
interaction between electrons and
photons but but other kinds of virtual
pions and all kinds of other things but
anyway
that's the idea of feminine diagrams so
they've been very successful
in in studying interactions between
electrons and photons it wasn't obvious
how they do
studying other kinds of interaction
processes let's say between
the pions that hold the nucleus together
and protons those are much stronger
interactions
so this idea that you can just work out
the first order and the higher order
terms will be small doesn't work anymore
because
the equivalent of alpha is a is a thing
that's about a 1 or even worse 10
and if it's the order 10 then the first
order term has a coefficient of 10
the next ordered term is 10 squared 100
so it's bigger
so you're not getting to things that are
smaller but in 1973 there was this
phenomenon discovered called asymptotic
freedom
which tells one that when you're dealing
with quarks and gluons which are the
things that are inside things like
protons
then the the higher the momentum
transfer essentially the more energetic
things are the lower the effective
coupling constant as it's called
the equivalent of this alpha quantity
gets and so
so there's a as as you increase the um
uh the sort of energies the effect of
coupling goes down
and it's quite quickly it's it's 0.1 and
then gets even smaller than that
and that means that you can use sort of
finding diagrams and the so-called
perturbation expansion
of first order finding diagram next
order next door to next order
and expect to get the right answer now i
mean there are a few footnotes here for
the little bit more mathematically
inclined folk
um one of the footnotes says that the um
uh in the kth order there are at least k
factorial
different diagrams possibly more um and
that means that so you've got a formula
that says alpha
k times k factorial well
for any value so k factorial
you know like 10 factorials 10 times 9
times 8 times 7 dot
dot 1 10 factorial
is going to be uh
it's um uh that's that's
a bit smaller than 10 to the 10 um but
it's something where
for any alpha to the k times k factorial
eventually the k factorial will always
be bigger than the alpha to the k
and so that means that eventually at
some very high order 100th order
with incredibly complicated diagrams
there'll be so many diagrams
that you'll expect that just the number
of diagrams
will be will make the contribution of
the hundredth order be really important
and that's bad news because
what we're doing is we're saying let's
just work out this this answer by just
looking at the very
low orders of of finding diagrams nobody
really knows
uh why or whether high order fimon
diagrams they don't appear to be
important
because otherwise we wouldn't be able to
get such good answers for things like
the anonymous magnetic moments
of the electron but quite why isn't
completely clear
some people argue it's really a square
root of k factorial
some people argue that there's more
cancellation in these diagrams than you
would expect
and so it's not really k factorial at
all et cetera et cetera but nobody
really knows
and so that's one of the sort of
continuing mysteries of chronic field
theory and environment diagrams and so
on
now another thing is you know if you
want to work out the scattering
electrons
in in quantum electrodynamics the theory
of electrons and photons
um is it really necessary to do all the
spyman diagram calculation or is there a
better way
well for about 70 years now people have
been looking for a better way
david feynman himself always used to say
i can't believe there isn't a better way
to do this
particularly as he saw people going to
these incredible lengths to do you know
year-long computer calculations
to work out some of his kinds of
diagrams well
so far we don't know a better way there
are some hints
from um uh ideas that come out of things
like string theory and
more conformal field theory there's a
fancy area which i could explain
sometime
of um of quantum field theory that
maybe possibly conceivably suggests
that there's a way to sort of relate
what happens with feynman diagrams
to what happens with things that look
much more like the theory of gravity
and uh that there might be a way to sort
of be able to just sort of bank work out
this is the answer you don't have to go
and work out all the individual famine
diagrams
actually with our uh current
approach to a fundamental theory of
physics it look it's looking quite
likely
that there will be a way different from
that way to do computations in quantum
field theory and do computations of
like the interactions between electrons
and photons um that will be quite direct
and will involve um uh looking at sort
of
the discrete elements that lie
underneath electrons and photons the
only
the bad news is we know how to do it for
sort of bulk
quantum fields but we don't really yet
quite understand what an individual
electron or an individual photon is like
and so we don't we can't quite yet do
those calculations but it's it's
something that is looking quite
promising
and maybe a way to kind of uh finally do
what dick feynman thought was possible
which is just don't work out all those
details with feynman diagrams
but um anyway so that's the idea of
finding diagrams they're they're
basically a representation of
microscopic processes that involve
things like electrons and photons
and they give you a calculational way to
figure out what the probabilities of
those kinds of interactions are
let's see
so question here
okay it's a question here from pranjul
how do holograms work
and why don't we have more holographic
technology
okay so um just a second
okay how do holograms work well first of
all what what is
a hologram so
when we look at a picture we're
basically
looking at uh a pattern well let's say
we look at a computer screen
the computer screen is is lit up there's
basically light coming from each part of
the computer screen to our eye
and we're seeing each pixel on the
computer screen might be a different
color so there might be a red pixel
next to a blue pixel next to a white
pixel we see that as some
piece of something or other and but
what's happening is
there's there's light coming straight
from the individual pixels on the screen
um that each of those pixels is emitting
light
and and when it emits light it might be
slightly directed but it's more or less
emitting it in all directions
and some of that light uh when we're
looking at it the screen from a
particular angle some of the light from
that pixel
will hit our eye and we'll say oh that's
a red pixel okay so that's how ordinary
vision ordinary images work okay
but what's happening
at a um uh let's see how to explain this
um
okay so in that picture what's going on
is it's as if we have little sort of
particles of light
that come from the screen and hit our
eye and it's like a
a p a red photon comes from the screen
hits our eye we
say okay that was a red pixel okay but
there's a different view of how light
works
which is not in terms of photons
particles of light but instead in terms
of waves
so we can also think of it as being and
these are
these are sort of complementary points
of view about what light really is
we can think of light instead as a wave
where instead of there being a photon
that is like this particle of light
coming from the pixel
instead the pixel is generating this
wave that's coming out of the pixel
that's that's
continually um uh being it's a continual
sort of variation of the electric
magnetic fields
that correspond to sort of what the
light is made of it's that continuous
variation
and that's a sort of a a wave that again
is is reaching our eye and so on now
when we think about light
uh there's some both of these
descriptions
are sort of mathematically valid when we
think about sort of the mathematics
of representing um uh light
uh which is ultimately an
electromagnetic wave when we think about
representing it
both of those descriptions the photon
the particle of light and the wave
they both end up when we actually
calculate what will be the intensity of
electromagnetic radiation that falls on
our eye
they're really just really different
ways to calculate the same thing
sometimes if if we have for example when
we have x-rays
gamma rays there's electromagnetic uh
radiation that has much shorter
wavelength much higher energy
per photon it's much more like oh
there's an individual photon there's an
individual photon and when we have radio
waves
it's much more like oh it's just a
smooth wave that's going on but they're
both
kind of limiting versions of the same
mathematics
okay so when we start thinking about
light in terms of waves
one of the things that we might try to
do is to say
let's uh let's try and reproduce the
wave fronts
let's try and reproduce the waves that
exist in the
electromagnetic radiation forget about
the the pixel
on the screen emitting a stream of
photons or something
just let's say let's set things up
somehow
so that we reproduce the sort of the
wavefronts of light
in the right way and so what holograms
are doing
is is essentially setting themselves up
to reproduce those wave fronts
it's like forget what the actual pixels
are like all we care about is
reproducing those wave fronts
and one of the things that's tricky is
that in order to reproduce those wave
fronts
uh when you have a if you have just a
stream of photons boom boom boom boom
photons coming out
um it doesn't really matter uh just
exactly what the uh what time each
photon came out it's just like okay i
received a red photon great
i'll receive another red photon etc when
you're dealing with waves
it really matters imagine waves on a
string you know you're wiggling the
string at one end and it's
it's having this wave go back and forth
it really matters
if you suddenly change how you're
wiggling it it really matters what the
timing of that change wiggle is
it matters what when that wiggle is
relative
to the the sort of the undulations in
the wave the phase of that wiggle
the phase meaning uh the the the sort of
phase of a wave is
when the wave goes from being being sort
of uh zero
up to its maximum value goes back to
zero again goes negative goes back to
its
to zero the phase is sort of where you
are in that cycle of going from zero
back to zero again
and so it can really matter if you're
sort of changing a wave
it can really matter what where that
change is relative to the phase of the
wave
and so what has to happen to make a
hologram to reconstruct
the set of wave fronts and so on you've
got to
basically be able to get
you've got to be able to have the right
phase information you've got to be able
to have
all those all those pieces of waves
be constructed with the right phase so
if you could do that then you can make
this sort of you can you can fake up
the exact wave fronts the exact pattern
of waves that corresponds to the light
if you can do that then as far as your
eyes are concerned you're just seeing
the light as it would be constructed
with those wave fronts
so the question is how do you how do you
fake up that phase
well when you use lasers are an
important piece of this
so when you have an ordinary light bulb
for example or
or for example the fluorescent lights
that usually are used for the
back lighting for computer screens those
kinds of things
um actually they're probably now led
lighting but either way
any any of those forms of lighting um
are
have the feature that they are not
coherent in the following
sense you can think of them as producing
pieces of light let's say photons or
they could be weight you could think of
them as waves
but whatever they're doing they're just
like uh okay
you know there's a uh you're producing
one little
little uh lump of light one little
photon one little piece of wave
and then a little bit later you produce
another one and they're kind of randomly
timed
there's no coherence between when those
pieces of light are being produced
and that's because let's say you're
producing light by just having an
incandescent filament you just
heated up a material what's happening is
the atoms and the material
are are being are being put in excited
states
and as they as they decay down to their
their ground state
they emit photons but when that decay
happens is completely random
so that means that the photons that are
coming out from the incandescent light
bulb
are coming out at all different times
there's no coherence to when they come
out
okay lasers work differently in lasers
what happens is uh it's it's um the
the the the word laser stands for light
amplification
by stimulated emission of radiation
what's happening is that
you are setting things up so that
essentially all the photons
instead of one piece of the of the of
the laser
are all coming out together and and
roughly
the um again it gets us off into a
slightly different topic but um
uh photons are a type of particle called
the boson
and bosons are particles that kind of
like to all be in the same state
if you start adding photons to something
the chance that you can add a photon to
something
uh is is larger if they're already
photons in the state of the photon that
you're trying to add
and so that means that in in a in a
laser
what you're doing is you're basically uh
you're organizing it so that there's
stimulation and emission of radiation
um and as opposed to the spontaneous
emission of radiation
that happens in like an incandescent
light bulb you're stimulating it by
having other photons be there
and those other photons are saying we're
in this state hey come join us and the
way photons work or boson particles in
general work
is they want to do that and so they all
end up in the same state
they all end up with the exact same
frequency
the exact same color of light and they
all end up
with sort of a wave that is coherently
produced and so in a laser
you get coherent light um and that means
that it's
it's not just photons coming out at
random times everybody's in phase
and that's what you need in order to
construct well
okay in the in the in the simplest form
of hologram
that's what you use in order to
construct um
uh in order to set up the phase
relationships so that you can get
the sort of reconstructed wavefront so
that you can see
things um in a way that is sort of
you've constructed this pattern of
of wave fronts in in space and as you
move your head around for example
you are you are seeing the the right
pattern of the wavefront
that corresponds to what the object
would look like if the part if the light
was coming from that angle or that angle
and i should have said when when a pixel
is emitting light i think i mentioned
it's sort of emitting the same light in
all directions when you've constructed
all these wave fronts
the wave fronts can be different on this
direction in that direction
and that means that it's it's just like
if there was a physical object there
where you look from a different angle
you look from another angle you see
different things
you've constructed the sort of the
structure of the wavefronts of light
that will correspond to that and you can
then you can then look from different
angles
um now there are also things for white
light holograms that
um well there's a whole whole collection
of different stories here
but but um the um uh okay
why is it difficult to make holograms
so what happens is when you make a
hologram what you're doing is you're
in the simplest way you're shining a
laser at this
pattern that is exactly producing
the right wave fronts but that hologram
in order to make those exact right wave
fronts the hologram
has to have little markings on it that
are about the wavelength of light and
size
okay so so light wavelength might be 500
nanometers
um 0.5 microns um
that will be uh um you know some
fraction of a millionth of a meter
um the uh so
in order to what you have to do to make
a hologram
you have to be able to have essentially
a display
okay to to define how those wavefronts
are going to work
you have to be basically sort of telling
the pieces of light
uh uh whether they whether they're going
to be
sort of emitted or not but you have to
do that as
a size that is comparable to the
wavelength of light
and the wavelength of light might be um
uh you know a fraction of a millionth of
a meter
and that means that in order to do that
in order to make a hologram you have to
be able to have something
where you can uh have sort of features
that are of that
order of scot size now if you're making
if you're
if you're sort of etching it out of some
plate
or something like this it's pretty easy
to make something that's that small
if you wanted to make it purely
electronically if you wanted to make it
like a display like the
like the you know like the light
emitting diode displays that we have
with the liquid crystal displays that we
have
if you want to be able to make sort of
pixels that are small enough
to be able to uh sort of control light
down at the
scale sizes about the wavelength of
light that's not been possible yet
perhaps that will eventually be possible
and that will allow one to actually have
a display
that is sort of a fully holographic
display where every
every individual pixel on the screen is
not controlling
it's not just saying emit light in all
directions but it's a piece it's
controlling just a part of the wavefront
of the light that's being produced so
that you're able to construct that sort
of elaborate wave front
that lets you kind of look around the
display and look from different angles
there are there are a whole bunch of
different ways to sort of
uh sort of approximate this using like
lenticular displays where you have
stripes that are going in different
directions and and so on
um but uh i think the the thing that
hasn't yet been possible
is to make displays where you can you
know be playing a movie
um right at the um uh at sort of the
the wavelength of light scale size so
that you can construct this kind of
constructed uh wavefronts of light now
in reality us humans don't really need
all the precise wavefronts of light
constructed because we just have two
eyes
and really most of our perception of
depth comes from the fact that
we have a parallax we're looking at an
object from two slightly different
angles
and as we compare what the object looks
like from those two slightly different
angles
we're getting a sense of how far away
the object is and so
if what we're trying to do is just give
us a sense of depth we don't need
a hologram we we need a hologram if we
want to look to the side of the object
and so on
but um we don't and and we don't need
that um
uh we just need to be feeding the right
signal with the right parallax to our
two eyes
and for example in vr headsets virtual
reality headsets
um this is kind of what's done is you're
just sort of feeding
the um uh you're feeding
sort of the image from a slightly
different angle to each as
as taken by camera to slightly different
angles each eye and then you're you're
getting the perception of
of sort of three-dimensional stuff with
depth and
and the way that a vr headset works it's
it's it's seeing
it's it's measuring with an
accelerometer it's measuring your head
moving around
and it's using that to be able to uh say
oh well you moved your head to that
angle
so i'll show you what that object looks
like from that side and one of the big
issues that vr
is making sure that that happens quickly
enough because
our brains are really sensitive to when
we when we move our head
does what we see change and if we move
our head and what we see doesn't change
it has a little delay that makes our
brains very confused and for somebody
like me for example
uh with with earlier vr headsets it
would take me only about
a minute to start feeling incredibly
motion sick uh from the kind of
lag that existed between the move your
head part
and the what the what the actual image
looks like but okay so that was a
a little bit of an attempt to talk about
holograms and why why they're not
more widely widely used um
so i think uh we should be wrapping up
fairly soon but um
uh let's see what we can talk about here
david brown asks have i read a book
called the deep learning revolution by a
person called teresanovsky
um terry has been a good friend of mine
for many years and he sent me many
versions of that book in fact
i even suggested its title it had a much
more nerdy title before that one
um but have i read every page i must
admit i probably haven't read every
page but it's a book about the history
of neural networks which terry was
was himself much involved in and it's
it's about um
the uh um it's a very upbeat book
about um about the history of of of
machine learning and neural networks and
uh terry himself has been particularly
involved in the question of
of modeling actual human brains and
seeing to what extent we can make
computational models
that approximate human brains and then
the realization that gosh those
computational models
are actually good for building
technological kinds of things
um and for being able to sort of do
things like object recognition
using artificial neural nets
the uh
io something or other it's asking how
closely do i follow the field of ai
i think it will be fair to say that i i
i
actually i like to think that i don't
follow the field i like to think i think
that i lead some of the pieces of that
field
um that i'm more leading than following
so to speak but yes i've been involved
in a lot of things that
have been at different times called ai
over the course of many many years
um and uh uh what what one means by
artificial intelligence sort of uh
intelligence implemented by computers
has changed a bit over the years
and in a first approximation as soon as
we really get good at doing something
it's no longer considered artificial
intelligence it's just
software of some kind we could talk
about some of the
some of the uh things that have happened
in that in that regard but but the
the whole field of of kind of what it
takes
to achieve sort of human-like
performance in different areas
is is this there's lots of different
pieces to that for example
our will from alpha system that powers
computational knowledge and things like
syria and alexa and so on that's an
example of something which for a long
time was thought of as being sort of a
a a sort of an ultimate goal of ai of
artificial intelligence was to make a
question-answering system
that could answer questions asked in
natural language about things in the
world
and for a long time people find it very
difficult to do that we finally sort of
cracked that problem
uh when wolf malpha came out back in
2009
but in a sense the way we cracked it
wasn't a very brain
like thing because what we're doing is
when you ask i don't know you know will
from alpha you say
uh you know what's the population of new
york
divided by uh um i don't know
luxembourg or something um what it's
doing is it's taking that natural
language it's converting it
into this precise computational language
that says the entity
new york city it is a city it's this and
that and the other
divided you know this function divide
you know the the population property of
that
the function divide et cetera et cetera
et cetera it's turning it into something
which is a a computer a computational
language a language
built to be understandable both to to
represent things that we humans care
about
and to be directly understandable to a
computer and so
in a sense the the um that what we've
achieved there is a very ai-ish thing
we've achieved this
you can answer a general knowledge
question um but the way we've done it is
something much more sort of
technological
and some of what uh for example terry
writes about in
and with respect to deep learning and so
on that's a story
of can you do things where where in a
sense
we aren't describing the algorithms by
which it works we're kind of expecting
it's sort of a magic thing
that can just learn from examples and so
a big piece of the kind of the this
whole sort of story of neural nets and
deep learning
is if you give a bunch of examples of
pictures of cats and a bunch of examples
of pictures of dogs
and then you show a picture do you
correctly recognize when it's a picture
of a cat and when it's a picture of a
dog
and it wasn't clear that was going to
work for many many years people had done
sort of built simple versions of that
and it didn't work
i mean this got started in the 1940s
people had the idea of doing this
by the 1950s there were already sort of
test examples made with electronics
that tried to do this and it
fundamentally didn't work or it worked
only in very restricted cases
you know for example by the 1980s doing
optical character recognition recognizes
that an a or a b
or a c whatever that got to be pretty
good so long as you knew there were 26
targets so to speak and you could kind
of
fix up the errors by knowing this is a
plausible word with these letters going
together and this isn't
um that was that ended up being
something that could be done but when it
came to
oh here a tenth out there about five
thousand picturable nouns
in english nouns that represent uh sort
of generic things that you could make
pictures of like
you know a chair a table a cat a dog and
they're about 5000 of those in english
and if you say can you recognize given a
picture
which of those 5 000 things this thing
is a picture of that hadn't been
possible
and what people imagined was
nobody really had any idea how many
examples you needed
to give and how the neural net needed to
kind of
learn to process that and then in 2011
actually due to
sort of a a chance thing that happened
um
there was a these these types of
so-called deep learning neural nets
that had many layers of of kind of um
functions that were being performed on
on the data um
the uh you could kind of try and train
one of those things it's a very
arduous process of of oh you see what
does it do with this input oh no that's
not right
you know propagate back the error that
happened with that input
okay show another input oh that wasn't
right propagated you know
the error was in this direction
propagate that back and you slowly try
and tweak
how the thing works and what wasn't
obvious
was that that tweaking would ever
actually work and how many samples you'd
need so the answer ended up being
for 5000 objects you need about 30
million samples
and um the training takes well when we
first did it
which was um 2014 or so
it took about three months of cpu time
um to do the training that was needed um
with 30 million samples
now by the way these days that's much
faster because
we've already pre-trained a lot of
things so we don't need to start from
scratch kind of
learning how to see a line learning how
i mean what's happening inside is not as
direct as learn how to see a line learn
how to see a circle
it's all smooshed together but that's
effectively what's happening but at this
point we already know the basic sort of
features to pick out of a picture
so we can we can sort of transfer that
learning
from uh from one neuron that to another
um it's kind of like a it's like we can
do a little bit of brain transplanting
which we don't get to do
uh in humans and it wouldn't work on
humans probably um
for for all kinds of reasons um but we
can kind of take these neural nets and
we can kind of say
there are these layers you can use those
and now you kind of learn
from the output of those and so the
thing that was surprising 2011 was
discovered that yes
uh you know if you if you put enough
effort into training and you have enough
examples you can actually recognize uh
those 5 000 picturable nouns decently
well
and that kind of started this whole sort
of revolution of deep learning which is
kind of a decent fraction of the way
through it's it's
it's sort of it's it's trajectory and i
think the you know what's what happened
is first there was image object
recognition
um then oh different kinds of things
like speech to text
was another one that got solved a few
years ago uh text translation is another
one that's sort of
in decent shape now um there you know
for example handwriting recognition
still isn't quite there yet uh if you
can see the person writing so you can
see the
sort of motion of the stylus it helps
you a lot but if you're just taking a
picture of the handwriting
not quite there yet they'll probably be
there in another couple of years
um then you know other kinds of
different things that um
uh that um uh get to be possible but
yes that's that's a um well there's a
big story there and i'm happy to talk
about it um another time
um let's see maybe
one last question and then i should um
should wrap up uh
oh boy okay there's a bunch of
philosophy philosophical questions here
maybe another time i'll
i'll um oh there's so many interesting
questions you guys are
you guys are um this is this is uh
unfair i'm supposed to go do my day job
here uh there's a question here from
mitchell
is it possible that long in the future
the universe will mostly
consist of star of iron stars how would
iron stars affect planets
with iron cores orbiting these stars
well okay
you know what's going to happen in the
universe in a long period of time
one of the things that seems to be
happening is everything's turning into a
black hole
so you know the center of our galaxy
there's this giant black hole it's like
a giant
garbage disposal at the center of our
galaxy
and steadily slowly things are falling
into it
and when we have a star for example
that's
a bit more massive than the sun uh stars
have different life cycles some of them
turn into supernovas one's bigger than
sun turns supernovas
some will turn into a white dwarf um the
uh
some stars just catastrophically
collapse into black holes
um but uh uh the the sort of the
the end state okay so there are
there are you know white dwarfs there
are um uh
uh neutron stars there are black holes
those are three common end states for
stars
um i guess if you if you wait long
enough to white with a white dwarf i'm
not i would suspect
that it does indeed turn into something
that's just full of iron
why on earth should things turn into
iron the reason is a slightly tricky
thing
so if you look at different uh if you
look at the different chemical elements
they're like a hundred and something
known each chemical element hydrogen
helium lithium beryllium boron etc
each successive chemical element has a
larger number of protons in its nucleus
so you go from you know you go from
hydrogen with one proton its nucleus
to you know uranium with 92 protons in
its nucleus
and then off to the the various kind of
radioactive elements i think we've got
up to about
122 maybe now is the
is the uh highest element that's been
that's been made
although it doesn't it doesn't survive
very long until its nucleus falls apart
um but anyway so you have all these
different all these different um
uh kinds of nuclei and um the um
these nuclei are all bound together by
the strongly clear force
and the one that's bound sort of the
strongest is the one sort of in the
middle of the periodic table
it's iron and actually iron 56
isotope 56 means 56 protons plus
neutrons
in the nucleus that is the most most
tightly bound atomic nucleus and so
if you're kind of saying well if you
throw all these neutrons and protons
together and so on
you get to the point where they have
sort of the maximum amount of energy
that that sort of go to the minimum
energy state it'll be the thing where
they're all bound together
like uh in in um in iron 56
so that's why that's why iron 56 is sort
of an end point to a bunch of these
nuclear reactions
now when you have a big a big star and
you've sort of smooshed together all
these nuclei
actually it'll turn into one big nucleus
that's what a neutron star is just a 10
kilometer across
sort of giant single atomic nucleus but
a black hole is what happens when when
the
with the amount of gravity is is larger
and it gets to the point where
uh that you know the escape velocity is
is the the
the gravity is large enough that the
escape velocity is more than the speed
of light
and and uh you you end up with something
which has an event horizon
where where light can go in one
direction but not the other so it looks
to everybody outside
as if it's black with no light coming
out of it so the the likely thing is
that a lot of our universe is going to
turn into black holes
um the it depends in detail on the
expansion rate of the universe whether
uh whether things sort of um you know
exactly what happens there but i think
the um um uh
the the the main story is uh
you know things turn into black holes
now if you ask the question if you're on
a planet
orbiting a star and the star turns into
a black hole
you know what does that mean for you on
the planet well the process of turning
into a black hole
is a pretty violent one and so that's
not a good good thing for you then we'll
be i actually don't know it's a good
question
um the shock wave generated by
gravitational wave emission
from a from a for example a black hole
merger i don't know what that would do
to a nearby planet
so for example in the um they're now
been about 50
uh black hole mergers observed so these
are black holes which are orbiting each
other
and then they slowly spiral and
eventually the two black holes hit each
other
and then they merge together and that's
a very violent event it's been observed
in the last about five years by
gravitational wave detectors
about 50 of those mergers have been seen
and it's fairly amazing because those
mergers are violent enough
they release enough gravitational
radiation that we can detect it
even halfway across the universe and for
example at this point i think the
largest furthest away one that's been
seen
is uh seven billion light years away so
that's uh that's half the age of the
universe
that's halfway across the universe
that's uh it's remarkable that we can
see an event
that took a few seconds to happen seven
billion years ago halfway across the
universe
and that's what happens when you see the
merger of two black holes
but when when that black hole merger
happens uh i think the first
very very first black hole merger that
was seen much closer than that one
um the amount of energy released in
gravitational radiation
was uh one and a half times the mass of
the sun so
in about a second or two there was
gravitational radiation
gravitational radiation is sort of
ripples in space-time
in the culture of space-time that um uh
produce forces of deformation on on
objects
so in um
the universe is expanding what does that
mean that means that the very structure
of space
is expanding and there's sort of a small
force that's trying to pull things in
space apart
it's it's a weak enough force that when
it comes to you know a star a galaxy
something like that those things are
bound together much more strongly
than the force that's pulling things
apart by the expansion of the universe
but there's a small force that's pulling
things apart by the expansion of the
universe
when you have a gravitational wave it's
a sort of
it's it's it's a kind of a wave like a
water wave or anything else
but it's a wave of deformation in the in
the
structure of space time so it's a wave
where things are being sort of
space-time is being pulled apart being
compressed together being pulled apart
compressed together
and so on these waves travel at the
speed of light and um
uh they're small deformation waves
and so any material object will be
deformed
by those will have a small force of
deformation associated with those
gravitational waves and so for example
the
gravitational wave detector basically
works by
by having these these masses that are a
certain distance apart
and as the space time deforms it pulls
these masses further apart or they go
closer together they're being it's being
the space-time is being deformed
and and the gravitational wave detector
is measuring that
so the question that you might ask is if
you were on a planet
near a a black hole merger what would
happen to you
there would be this intense uh burst of
gravitational radiation
that would be um uh where where it's
like the equivalent of the whole mass of
the sun
being turned into gravitational
radiation in a second so that's
very intense gravitational radiation
intense enough that you know a third of
the way across the universe we can
detect it
um so what would happen to you on a
planet nearby interesting question
so i i think hmm um the real question is
what is the
uh you know would everything on the
planet be sort of torn apart by the
gravitational wave
going through it i i would suspect the
answer is yes but i don't
actually know let me think um
[Music]
let's see gravitational plane wave well
it isn't a plane wave it's a it's a it's
sorry i'm
i'm going into physics speak it's a it's
a it's probably better approximated as a
spherical wave something where
where the the fronts of the wave instead
of being all parallel
are all uh are sort of spherical shells
and um so what would that do
i think i think what would happen is
there will be violent
title forces tidal forces meaning uh
like on the earth you know that the
the the water on the earth for the tides
is both
pulled by the moon when it's closer to
the moon and it goes further away from
the earth when it's further from the
moon that's
that's because um of the difference in
the in the forces associated with
pulling the center of the earth and
pulling the stuff slightly close to the
moon
slightly further from the moon so it
tends to to elongate things in a certain
direction so my guess is
that there will be sort of violent tidal
forces on the planet
and i think it would be tough to survive
a solar mass of gravitational radiation
sort of passing through your planet um
but i'm not sure
but but let's assume you survived that
and that would be a black hole merger
and i think the formation of black hole
might be a little different
it might be a supernova which will be a
huge uh huge amount of energy released
that would also cause you trouble as a
planet but but imagine
uh well imagine like in the situation
with our solar system where the star is
small enough that we'll just turn into a
white dwarf
and maybe eventually sort of go out and
turn into something that's no longer
having nuclear reactions happen
uh you know what would happen to the
planet um as far as the gravity of the
star is concerned doesn't make any
difference
if there's a certain amount of mass
inside the star
that the the gravitational field outside
of the star will stay exactly the same
so the planet will keep orbiting
it might get really cold because there
isn't any you know there's no
energy being being uh produced by the
star at that point
but i don't think um you know the planet
wouldn't the the process of forming
a neutron star a black hole whatever
that's a violent process and so that
would do all kinds of all kinds of
things but i think
once you have uh you know if it was a
white dwarf that sort of just went out
and turned into a
a thing made a big star made of iron um
i think that um
uh i don't think there'd be any reason
why the planet should do anything other
than just
keep orbiting its star um albeit uh
you know better have another source of
energy it better be the case the planet
had a bunch of radioactive elements
inside it or something
that can produce heat because otherwise
otherwise you're not getting a lot of
energy there
all right i should wrap up for now um so
uh
thanks everyone for for joining us here
and uh be back again next week so
bye for now